a lo largo de nuestras vidas nos han
dicho que comamos ciertos alimentos
porque contienen vitaminas o a veces nos
pueden decir que también contienen
algunos minerales que necesitamos por lo
tanto la pregunta más obvia aquí es que
son las vitaminas y qué son esos
minerales de los que nos hablan bueno
existen algunas cosas que nuestro cuerpo
necesita en un momento hablaremos del
por qué necesita todo eso pero también
hay cosas que nuestro cuerpo necesita y
que además no produce el cuerpo no lo
produce hay muchas cosas que nuestro
cuerpo necesita y que es capaz de
producir pero hay otras cosas que no
puede producir por sí mismo ahora sí
estas cosas que nuestro cuerpo necesita
y que no puede producir son orgánicas
esta es una forma elegante de decir que
hay moléculas en las que se involucran
los carbonos la mayoría de las moléculas
en la vida involucran muchos carbonos a
esas moléculas les llamamos moléculas
orgánicas
hecho hay un campo entero en la química
que es la química orgánica que estudia
la química de la mayor parte de la vida
estas moléculas orgánicas que el cuerpo
necesita y no puede producir se llaman
vitaminas y algunas de las vitaminas más
comunes de las que nos hablan son la
vitamina a vitamina de vitamina e
vitamina k vitamina c y podemos dividir
a las vitaminas basándonos en si son
solubles en grasa o no por ejemplo las
vitaminas a d e ica
todas estas vitaminas son solubles en
grasa eso qué significa
bueno al ser solubles significa que se
disuelven en grasa mientras que la
vitamina c es soluble en agua ahora la
razón por la que esto puede ser
relevante para usted es viviendo como un
individuo que trata de mantener su salud
en buen estado es que todos necesitamos
estas vitaminas aunque al menos con las
vitaminas solubles en grasa puede
existir una sobredosis porque como son
solubles en grasas se quedan en nuestro
sistema más tiempo mientras que las
vitaminas solubles en agua son más
fáciles de sacar del sistema pensemos en
algunos alimentos que encontramos
normalmente y algunas de las vitaminas
por las que son conocidos aquí tenemos
unas zanahorias y tal vez hayan
escuchado decir oye comí zanahoria son
buenas para tus ojos y eso es muy cierto
pero la razón por la que son buenas para
nuestros ojos es porque las zanahorias
contienen algo conocido como
betacaroteno y la palabra caroteno no es
coincidencia pues significa zanahoria en
latín y los carotenos son las moléculas
de pigmento que le dan a las zanahorias
ese color anaranjado tan particular
entonces una vez que el betacaroteno es
consumido por nuestro cuerpo se
convierte en un precursor de la vitamina
y que es esencial para nuestros ojos y
muchas otras cosas en nuestro cuerpo
precursor es solo una forma elegante de
decir que si consumimos betacaroteno
nuestro cuerpo puede convertirlo en la
vitamina que necesita ahora vamos con
las naranjas famosas por la vitamina c
esta no es una lista muy larga de todo
lo que contienen estos alimentos pero
podemos mencionar algunas de las cosas
por las que son más famosos y en este
caso la vitamina c es una vitamina
soluble en agua que es muy importante
para el sistema inmune porque por
ejemplo en una situación en la que se
tiene una deficiencia severa de vitamina
c podemos contraer una enfermedad
conocida como escorbuto y aunque el
escorbuto ya no es tan común hace
cientos de años
los marineros sufrían comúnmente de
escorbuto debido a que tenían dietas muy
limitadas no comían frutas y verduras y
debido a esa deficiencia de vitamina c
su colágeno es decir su tejido conectivo
se descomponía era una enfermedad muy
y dolorosa pero qué pasa cuando nuestro
cuerpo necesita algo que no produce y no
es orgánico bueno esos son los llamados
minerales y claro el término mineral
también se utiliza en un sentido
geológico pero si hablamos en términos
de biología eso es lo que queremos decir
y los minerales más comunes en realidad
son elementos que podemos encontrar en
la tabla periódica como el fósforo pero
solo voy a escribir su símbolo fósforo
calcio potasio magnesio hierro zinc
entre otros esta no es una lista muy
larga pero todos estos minerales son
esenciales para nuestro cuerpo y
conforme avanzamos en nuestro estudio de
la biología podemos ver cómo el fósforo
es muy útil en moléculas como el atp que
almacenan energía y también se encuentra
en la cadena del adn y del arn por otro
lado podemos encontrar que el calcio es
muy útil no solamente
y huesos sino también en otras cosas
como las contracciones musculares para
enviar señales a través de las neuronas
necesitamos el potasio y también un poco
de sodio el magnesio también es muy
importante para la contracción muscular
el hierro se encuentra en la hemoglobina
se une con el oxígeno y permite que
podamos transportar el oxígeno a través
del torrente sanguíneo en los glóbulos
rojos de la sangre así que todos estos
elementos son muy importantes ahora
muchos de los alimentos que ya dijimos
que contienen vitaminas también
contienen minerales por ejemplo las
zanahorias no solamente contienen
betacaroteno también contienen potasio
que es esencial para las funciones del
sistema nervioso la leche contiene
vitaminas como la vitamina t pero
también tiene minerales como el calcio
que como ya dijimos es esencial para los
huesos y funciones musculares entonces
aquí lo más importante es que las
vitaminas y los
minerales son dos cosas que nuestro
cuerpo necesita y que no puede producir
por sí mismo y los veremos una y otra
vez en biología así que no los pierdan
de vista conforme avanzamos más y más en
el estudio de biología podemos encontrar
a las vitaminas como co enzimas que
ayudan a facilitar reacciones y los
minerales los podemos encontrar en todo
desde la central eléctrica de la célula
la cadena de adn también los
encontraremos en las contracciones
musculares en la formación de los huesos
la hemoglobina y en las funciones
nerviosas hemos terminado nos vemos en
otro vídeo